Speaker 1: Now let's move on to the shedding
vaccine conspiracy that came from this event. All
right. So after consistently speaking out against
vaccinations for years and years and years,
silk of diamond and silk, remember Diamond is
Alethea Lynnette Hardaway, who recently died,
we believe, of COVID unvaccinated silk, is now
suggesting that Diamond died because of the
vaccine. I actually had to look at the clip I'm
going to play for you a bunch of times to figure
out even what was the conspiracy theory that Silk
is putting out there. Initially, I said, well,
how did Diamond die of the vaccine? Because,
remember, they didn't seem to be vaccinated.
This was what they said about the vaccine. Yes.
Speaker 3: We don't need to look at the Kimberley.
Right. But what we don't need to happen is
what happened with Africa, Right. When Bill
Gates and them took that vaccine to Africa. Yeah,
vaccinate. They felt like stuff can start right
there in certain parts of Africa. That's what we
don't need to. You not don't make black people,
not the guinea pig. But if we're right here, be
yo spare. No yo yo project. Not black yet today,
Bill. Yes, the sergeant the sergeant general
was talking to. As a matter of fact, he was
trending today. Listen, I tell us what we need to
know. Yeah, but I always look at the underbelly
of what's going on. That's intuition in me.
Speaker 1: So needless to say, their intuition
led them not to be vaccinated. So then we go to
the memorial service. Here is Silk eulogizing
Diamond. I had to listen a bunch of times, but
I believe what she's saying here is Diamond was
poisoned by coming into contact with vaccinated
people, other people having been vaccinated,
killed. Diamond, by the way, she says
this with Trump, they're sitting four feet
away. Who takes credit for the vaccines?
Speaker 3: Are Americans being poisoned?
Speaker 1: Ah ha.
Speaker 3: In the wild
when they want to depopulate and
sterilize a large group of animals?
They usually and jack one animal. Right. And then
that one animal. In fact, the rest of the animals.
Speaker 1: Oof!
Speaker 3: So technically and
according to the science.
Speaker 1: Oh.
Speaker 3: It doesn't matter
if you're vast or not. Ah.
As long as the gain of function allows
one injected person to transfer and affect
another person and that person affect another
person, eventually everyone will be affected
in one way or the other.
Speaker 1: Now understand
she's not talking. It's you would hear that and
say, oh, she's describing how a virus spreads, all
right. Like one person gets infected and then the
next and the next. The next. No, no, no, no, no.
She's talking about the vaccine. And what's
amazing is Trump's vaccinated and he's sitting
four feet away. If you believe this, does Silk
really believe this? I have no idea. I really
couldn't tell you. If Silk really believes this,
then Trump's presence there is a major danger to
everybody who's in the crowd because Trump
would be shedding vaccine or whatever. Now,
we've talked about this many times before. This
concept of shedding vaccine is the idea that
if you're vaccinated, you can spread. There's
different versions, there's you're vaccinated,
you can spread the virus by shedding it out of
the vaccine. Not possible because the current
vaccine doesn't have active virus in it. That's
not possible. Or you're vaccinated and you're
shedding vaccine. Now, that's not true. All that
would happen is maybe other people would end up
vaccinated, but that's not actually what
happens. The COVID vaccines don't contain
live virus. It's impossible. It doesn't happen.
It doesn't happen. How insane is this at the.
We believe that Diamond died of COVID. We as far
as we know, they are not vaccinated. And Silk
starts doing the conspiracy theory that Diamond
may have been poisoned by vaccinated people.
I guess shooting particles of the vaccine all
around them like a cloud of sorts. These are very,
very sick people. And they're we don't
I don't minimize or dismiss their grief
by any means. But even in their grief, they
continue to actively do damage to the world
that chooses to follow science and empiricism and
common sense and try to act in ways where we are
sort of trying to help those around us. Very,
very sad. And there are four or five different
tragedies all altogether here. Not just that
we believe Dymond died of COVID unvaccinated,
but there's a bunch of other tragedies here
as well. We'll have all of these clips that
I played for you on our Instagram. You can find
us on Instagram. It's quite intuitive. In fact,
you just search for David Pakman show on
Instagram. You'll find all of these clips.
You can also find them on our YouTube channel
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.